yeah hi evening and welcome to Auntie
Jenny's podcast I ain't been there for a
while Phil's got a day off so I'm here
and um
we're talking about women hate in cells
but create them didn't know what it
meant had to look it up just want to let
you guys not know I've been quiet for
the last few weeks because I had to be
now I don't have to be no I'm not going
to be so we've got a panel of our women
and one man one lucky man and um I've
been watching all the
programs lately and
that [__] ain't gonna happen on my show
and now we've got security here
but
ain't happening
so for once we're gonna have the man to
go first
I want to know um
I know your name your age your
relationship status
what's your favorite thing to do with
your other half or eight other
starting with you okay do we promote our
handles as well and go for it all right
cool I'm ghost the writer I'm spelled
with a at the end
um I do everything within the creative
space you name it
um from poetry I was a poet
um focusing now on designing Interiors
properties
done um
image consultancy
and dating coach
um
yeah it's complicated but
I do like quality time
um when you've got
someone who's your other half that's
like your friend it's just organic
it doesn't feel forced
um you could do anything it could be the
simplest thing like
just watching films watching TV
um it doesn't have to be anything
extravagant obviously I like the usual
going on holidays Etc but just simply
laying on the couch watching something
I like that so that's your favorite
thing to do isn't it
yeah it's just nice this is organic just
it's white it's winding down so I like
to wind down with my partner that
usually involves like films okay yeah so
you're in a relationship now
um I'm in a complicated situation
at the moment wow you're gonna ask you
about that later okay I've heard the
situation ships but
is that a situationship no no it's more
than that but um I'm just yeah all right
yeah
any young lady my name's Christine
um
I'm 22. single and my favorite thing to
do
um with another half would be going for
sushi
okay
hi my name's Carmen I'm 25 and
I'd like going for walks nice long walks
along the Thames
well obviously other places but like
okay we're close to home yeah
okay um I'm Shannon I am 34. I am single
and my favorite thing to do probably
with my other half
something that's a bit fun I quite like
bowling I'm a bit competitive so you
know something we can we can do together
like that
okay
thank you
um hi I'm sakaina I'm 28 years old I'm
taken and my favorite thing to do with
my partner is try different food
I'm a foodie he's a foodie
we love to go to different restaurants
and try different Cuisines okay what's
your favorite risk what's your favorite
Cuisine to eat at the moment
um I love
Greek food yes
yes right now the title that they've
given me because I didn't know if I've
got here was women hitting cells but
create them I'd look it up
and an insulin is a member of an online
community of a young man who considered
themselves unable to attract women
sexually
typically associated with views are
hostile to those women and men who are
usually who are sexually active
so
have anybody met any in cells have you
ever heard that word before no yeah you
say it again in sales in cell i n c e l
s
they've never heard of it so you've
never heard about the women talking
about all their men that troll over
people and if somebody's in a
relationship and they can't get a woman
and they hate women because they can't
get a woman because everybody's having
sex but then so I've had clients like
that but I've never heard of that term
if I'm being honest so but the
description based on what you're saying
um yeah I get it as like someone who's
got resentment because they can't get
women like
in that sense is that correct yeah okay
okay so have you met anyone like that or
seen anyone yeah about clients like that
yeah but they like describe them not
them in person but the type of person
that they are how would you spot one
what they like
um
so usually like
they're kind of angry at the fact that
they can't get
um women and they have
a lot of negative things to say to both
parties like your description yeah um
and then it's like a spiral of
negativity and then there's a community
of like-minded people who kind of
console each other
and instead of kind of doing something
about it I feel like they kind of
egg each other one a little bit but um I
feel like there are potentially things
they can do to improve their prospects
like what
um appearance confidence
um
like just understanding how the opposite
sex works okay and um yeah it's kind of
just like learning learning
learning what they want and not like
trying to be someone different being
organic to yourself within reason by
making tweaks because it's unauthentic
when you try and be someone that you're
not and it's evident so
you can't tell someone to be someone
totally different it's not going to get
them very far it's just like but
tweaking and managing
with who they are understanding your
clan or whatever
and understanding what kind of partner
they want and seeing if their
expectations match what they are because
a lot of the time people want something
that maybe is not achievable or
realistic for them do you know what I
mean so so Grandpa his description of
mine
you still never met anyone like that or
knowing anybody out there or heard of
anyone like that nobody here I've
who's heard of it yeah I have yeah yeah
what have you heard the same kind of
thing yeah anyone like that I I know
people who
like just scream Mena trash 24 7 and
they've kind of convinced themselves
that they're just gonna be alone now and
there's no one out there for them
so what do you think causes that
I don't know I think dating the wrong
people making poor decisions
um
when dating and we're talking about
instills and normally people that can't
get dates
I mean women turn them down they're
angry about it because everybody's
having sex with them aren't they also
just men in cells yeah yeah uh so they
are okay sorry I thought it was the oh
okay so it's just men that are basically
resentment yeah okay
what do you think causes resentment in
men like that what do you think makes
them feel like that because the title is
that women create them rejection female
standards
I think female standards cause that
resentment in men sort of understand is
that you see that women have
um
you hear a lot of the talk about high
value man someone who earns six figures
someone who has multiple streams of
incomes
um you know the lavish lifestyle yeah
but realistically that's not going to be
everyone so I think Pearl talks about it
a lot you have the majority of women
fighting over a minority of men
typically the top 20 percent
so the left the the men that who are
left is 80 of men now some of them are
going to be in cells yeah but I don't
think it's 80 of men and I feel like now
that word is being thrown around
like I mean it might be about 30 of me
yeah and of the 80 that are not like
high value it might be about 30 but why
do you think nobody what do you think
about the women and these 30 that's what
I wouldn't know I think it's hypogamy
why are they getting none why aren't the
women going for them yeah hypogamy so
like
um it just means that women typically
want to date above their level at the
minimum their level so
um you can get average girls but he went
above average men in every kind of
factor so
financially uh looks aesthetically yeah
so whatever whatever field they want to
be like
a superior man but obviously
um that doesn't account for all men
that's not like the majority of men so
the those quote unquote remain this some
of those like
um she just said
will take that in a in um we'll take
that badly
and become this term that you said
intels another thing as well is that um
some of them may have
been missold the story like often you
hear like
women say ah they just want someone nice
and
someone like to look after them Etc but
I feel that there are a lot of those
kind of guys
but they get friend zone so
I guess some insoles might have tried
thinking all right let me be nice
to to this girl whatever got their heart
broken
real realize that life isn't like that
and sometimes a nice guy might finish
last and then they're put into that
position so all they like they start
hating the guys that
do get those girls and then hate the
women
that rejected them
yeah can I saw the single women describe
your ideal man please
who wants to go first it's a really good
question
um
for me
someone who
at least has I don't know the feeling I
want to know by first of all just by
looking at him what would he look like
cool
um I would know he's he's I want to know
what he looks like and I wanna know what
job you love I wanna know what he went
what kind what kind of place he live in
and what he would drive four things
okay
um
I don't really have a specific look that
he needs to look like
um one thing I do want is them to be
taller than me how tall are you five
foot six okay
um they don't have to be over six foot
but I would like it if they're taller
than me
um they don't have to be ripped but I
don't want someone overweight
[Music]
um
and job
as long as they're doing something that
they can be content in I'm not really
too fast
um
a minimum salary of probably 40 000 I
think is enough to get by and survive
okay
um
Drive
um the the car
I'm not really too fast as long as it's
got four wheels and it moves okay and
what was the other
other one home home
um
a three-bedroom house okay
okay um I'll go next
um so I am quite tall I'm like five
eleven and a half so
I I would like a guy who's taller than
me but sometimes that's uh can be a bit
difficult
um because I think for a woman I'm kind
of above average in height
um but yeah my ideal mate would be
um at least my height 511.
um it's okay
um in terms of a job
um
I am someone who would like a man to
have an above average income when I say
average
um you know I think the average income
in the UK is something like you know 41
000 pounds
um if I'm already earning more than that
then I would like my partner to also be
at least matching that or earning more
than that
um
and I think that just comes from how I
was raised you know my father was an
entrepreneur he had his own business
um you know my mom also worked as well
but you know in our household he was
able to kind of give us you know
anything that we wanted holidays um as a
family every single year you know which
I which I really loved so I would
definitely you know when I have kids
have have um you know a man in my life
who can
um be able to provide those things
um I'm also an entrepreneur myself so I
like the freedom that comes along with
um entrepreneur online income so I'm
ideally looking for someone who is
entrepreneurial minded
um in terms of the car I mean I'm not
really a car person so um you know like
she said as long as it moves I mean a
nice car like you know I like Range
Rovers if I'm if I'm gonna buy a car
that's going to be my that's going to be
my next one um but he doesn't have to
have
um that kind of a car
um in terms of a house as well I would
like
when I do settle down I would like a
nice home
um
I would say at least three bedrooms
especially if we're planning for kids
and again I'm just comparing it to you
know what I did have back home and you
know home I do own in Canada that is you
know it's actually four bedrooms um it's
quite nice so
so yeah that's that is what I'm looking
for
[Laughter]
um job
right so I live in London so anything
fully legal I don't want no side hustle
of any extra young man would have
already sleep no once he brings in the
paper packet that's what you want
because otherwise
I
don't want none of that I get on the
road no I want everything legal
so just making that very clear
um what celery though
40 40 45
Bridge
um
home
well I've got a two bed myself so
probably a two bed for themself because
I don't feel like I want to have a man
live with me so he'd have to have his
own place he's like no intention of
getting married
none
um I do obviously know that I've
probably will have another child with
somebody else so it'd be nice for them
to have their own room in their house
away from me I've got no intention of
getting married oh
she's just gonna be a baby mother I
don't need I won't even look at her
um my child's mum
if you have more than one you'll be a
baby yeah then I'll be a baby right now
on the charge my boss but you plan on
being a baby mama
you just said it yeah but I don't
even down like
like down to the club are you coming on
the counseling show you're gonna yeah
I'm gonna come you need it yeah
I called into the standards out there if
somebody has to look at you
the women
I wonder what would they rate you at one
to ten and why do you think they'd rate
you there
hmm
um Society standards yeah five
um
I think I'm average looking
yeah
okay
whoever wants to jump okay
um
I think it depends on the type of man so
if it's
um
how do I say this so I'm mostly date
Blackman so
um you know Africans Caribbeans I would
say maybe I'm like a seven but by white
standards obviously I'm overweight so I
would say I don't know I think I got a
nice smile I got nice eyes I got other
things going for me but I would say like
maybe like a five
okay
I'll say about six
I was just looking at all the all the
things that the women wanted from a man
and then you've got rated yourself
and I find that sometimes women have
problems
oh that's how they create the in cells
because your standards compared to you
just awaited yourself five sixes what
did you rate yourself six six seven if
it's if it's a black man a six or seven
six six and a five right
would you be if a man came up to you and
said I'm a five would you accept him
would you be willing to take a man
that's a five
average looking yeah would you be
willing to take a 500 yeah
do you know what a five would look like
because I got in the middle sitting
there and thinking I don't care what
they say about me I am not taking a
fight I don't care how big they say I am
I don't care how short they are I am not
she looks at me like you really want me
to be over five yeah I'm talking to you
okay I guess um
uh
no probably not because of you know the
the men that I've dated in the past
um I would consider you know them much
above a five
um you know I I've I've dated you know a
lot of very good looking men in my
opinion anyways my good looking could be
very different to somebody else's good
looking
um so no
but do you see how intels are created
yes I do I definitely do you think it is
that intels who creates in cells
I think there's a lot more to a person
than yeah I mean it has to be a
combination so
um let's say I mean if someone isn't in
sale it'd be it'd be interesting to know
um what their experience with women have
been yeah
according to the um no they're virgins
The Virgins have been really nice try to
talk to a woman the woman looks at them
says yeah you're average I don't want
you and then they go with somebody that
is maybe a seven or eight that would
just sleep with them and just leave them
and dump them so that man gets angry
against men and it gets angry against
women right so as women all here I'd
like to know who do you think creates in
sales and why do you how do you think
they're created women we control the
access to everything only six not
marriage at all but yeah yeah I
completely agree with you
um
but you know for obviously if you're
saying that these men's are virgins then
of course it's the women creating that
because women control the access to sex
yeah but sorry I can I jump in go
through once you don't interrupt me he's
looking to interrupt each other
um I do feel like people need to take
responsibility for their own kind of
like actions and like
how they choose to live their life like
you can't just blame other people for
the reason why you're single there's
women who are alone as well
and you know what women are alive
there's a lot of women who are alone no
I'm just asking what kind of women I
love because if a woman wanted to go
there's women
they pass a certain age we're talking
about Good Old we're not going for we're
not going for old women we're not going
for leftover women we're going about men
on DJ the 30 who are working hard they
might not be they might be about five
foot tall they might be five five they
might even be earning 45 000 a year they
might not drive
that's the kind of man we're talking
about we're not talking about you know
old women and old women we're talking
about men in their Prime who are ready
who are nice who are willing to settle
down with women but the women don't want
them because
the women's standards are so high yeah
but I also don't I feel like this term
of like nice guys is I don't like it
because I feel like a nice guy is just
an entitled guy just because you're nice
you expect women to like you but what
else are you bringing to the table you
can't just sit there and be like you're
nice you have to have other things what
else like it needs to be able to keep
the woman in a relationship right what
would you I mean these men are even they
haven't got to first base they even get
to go out on a date so maybe you're
boring maybe you're boring but how would
they know maybe you haven't got a game
you're not interested
captivating like there's so so what film
I'm going right a woman wants a man
who's interesting captivating's got all
the gab and it's not boring have
something about how many of us men out
there settle down with women how many of
those men that you're describing
actually settle down with women
marry them and settle down with women
I don't know firstly I don't think those
guys would get a chance to
all right so say if a guy's got like
good personality or whatever yeah but
you found them ugly by Society standards
or whatever like
just unattractive I don't think you'll
get to that stage or rarely
to know his personality you know I mean
to know whether he's born normally guys
are we talking about now I'm saying
normally those people may be in a work
environment you might get to know him
that way but on on the street in a club
whatever you're not going to pay him no
man those kind of guys I don't think
they would
get
um a look in yeah I don't believe that
it's weird for everyone we're talking
about if you work out how many people
are in the world there's not somebody
out there for everyone but we're just
talking about the fives we're talking
about the average bug standing five five
or four remember
why don't the women who are fives go
with fives why is it that the women are
allowed to go like we've had women here
describe that she's a seven she don't
want to go over five so how come it's
okay for women to have a choice but if
men have a choice it's if men say oh you
know well it's like there's something
wrong with you you ain't got game you're
boring yeah but it's exactly the same as
if as if if a woman was a five she also
would have like not that much um
because sadly swiping for her on a date
now no no no like sadly to say
um a lot of men if we were talking about
sex now yeah let's be real so a lot of
men are a bit a bit indiscriminate about
who they have sex with like I'm seen as
relatively selective compared to a man
you know I'm saying a prime I pride
myself in that but I'm not gonna allow a
lot of man who yeah even if you're like
sub power like attraction level as a
woman a lot of guys would have sex
I think insoles a lot of it is stemming
from in even getting to first base Third
Base whatever you call it so sexual or
just normal interaction before you even
can consider marriage you know what I'm
saying so those like it doesn't the
leftovers are men the insoles are men
not women because if you think about it
if women are dating up like hypogamy
then the leftover people are those guys
like I said I've had clients like that
they
they women are not gonna go down whereas
those guys would go if I gave them a
girl that was like not really that
attractive they would take they would
take that girl yeah but I think that's
just that's depending on I think that
just means that men and women have
different requirements that's all it is
you guys have less non-negotiables and
we have more no no negotiables no we
have a lot but that's different the
women have more non-negotiables right
that's where there's so many yeah lonely
sad women out there that's true who have
run up all these men because every man
that they see that they think yeah
that's a nice guy those men are only
interested in sex whereas you can get an
in cell and you eat that's husband
material yeah it doesn't look like
husband material he's a grower well I
call these a grower and they've got
other words for Growers young ladies but
I'm being instant now he's a grower he's
somebody you can grow with so that's
where the imbalance is
women don't want to go with fives men
some we're grateful 12-5
but then the women go out there and they
will have all these seven eights nines
because you cannot swim in on the panel
like what's the highest number you've
had for a man
you any of your exes what would you what
would you mark your highest exerting
six okay
she's probably an exceptional don't wait
for me to tell you oh what the highest
did you say about eight nine okay
yeah same and that's what I mean
if you look at all of them the eight
nine she says she's a fire she went over
six you said it was what number
six have you been out with what someone
was like eight nine but I've been with
someone that's five four but what I'm
trying to say is that but you're not
with him no I went because he was boring
no that's the crazy one but you know
what I mean crazy
honey you know what the problem is yeah
they'll be like we said they'll be left
over guys like you call insoles them
them nice guys that we described that
were in the friend zone and didn't get
women they find it hard to have sex but
then you have leftover women who get to
a certain age that have dated or slept
around with all the the guys that they
found nice or attractive but now they
got to an age and then now they're left
over for marriage so you get left over
older women for marriage and leftover
men that are in Souls because then those
other guys are gonna go and date younger
women
and replace the older women to get so
they're gonna get they're kind of not
Karma but it's gonna balance out in that
sense so I guess maybe them Undateable
insoles
should end up with
the leftover women I don't know maybe
yeah exactly what I was saying there's
someone out there for everyone can I
just ask the women
you went out with yeah what was the
highest you ever been out with before
your man you're gonna say like the man
your number what's the highest rating
you've been at without a ten
um oh god
um
I don't know God I don't rate them uh
would you rate yourself how would you
rate yourself because everybody else got
raped how would you rate yourself
probably a myself
solid eight
what makes you an eight
um if you start from a ten right you
start from a 10 10 is perfect 10 is when
nobody can say anything bad about you
nobody can take anything away so if you
start with a 10 and then take off what
you think that
would lower that Mark
so that means that you're down to what
are the two scores that you went down on
I think I've got some toxic traits
so that's that's that makes you a nine
or else
um
I need to learn to cook more so basic
things right so that's that's so that's
the only things you need to work yeah
that's it really I think I've um I've
been raised well I've worked hard my
whole life I'm a good person
um I respect myself I have strong morals
I just think there's some toxic traits
that I need to work on and I need to
become a little bit more traditional and
prepare myself for marriage
what are you gonna do to make yourself
more traditional
um
what do you need to change to make
yourself traditional I I think I need to
be a little bit more
um mature about things like finances you
know like
managing my money
um just I don't know a bit embarrassed
like cleaning my room cleaning my house
like just becoming a little bit more
what's the word domesticated do you live
alone no I live with my family all right
so you don't live with you yeah man no
not yet no
I'm I'm trying to prepare myself to be
that perfect wife
um
year and a half now as you've seen your
roommate is worse yeah and he's still
with you
he's watching this
you're with a nasty woman
I'm actually really embarrassed she
should be embarrassed you're taking her
out for a meal and leaving the room like
that with all the clothes everywhere
where she's been trying to get the
clothes shame on you man shame on you
in sales cost you two it's men like you
you see you go and pick up the women and
then look what you're picking up and you
could have gone out there and got five
and you've got a woman that says she's
an eight a five would have been cleaning
the house that's what you have to
understand there's nothing wrong with
fives you've got seven that looks good
and can't clean
seven adults sort of messy in the house
right anyway that's this is me I just
had to say you know do you know one
thing to like add this left
it's a vicious circle for those insults
you know because those lack
guys who get girls
and so those insults don't get girls
it's like
the more those other guys will be
desired and they'll be undesired so
Slack it's the only like I was going to
ask you like what's because I've had
clients like that they're like
can you tell us about it like you know
obviously don't say names but tell us
about your clients like when you say
you've you've worked with clients who
are in sales like I'm just trying to
think in my head what kind of guy is an
in sale like what what okay what kind of
job does he have yeah
I know a guy right and he's a lovely guy
he's really nice he's kind he helps
people he studies he works he's quite
tall
his dress sense isn't the best and he
hasn't got the best features in the
world now when he approaches a woman
he's excuse me and please no girls just
look at him as if his piece of [__]
because the way he approaches them hello
pleased to meet you you don't get past
that whereas he sees a man that are like
that hey
yeah what are you doing tonight babe and
those are the ones that get the women
okay that's sad he's a really really
nice guy so what I want to know is that
you went out of a six the highest as a
fight what made you deserve a six why
are you in above
what made you deserve a six nothing made
me deserve it but I do think that there
is a biological tendency as to why I
went up
um how'd you get a six how'd you get him
I don't know you just got him yeah okay
where'd you meet him
why did I meet him three friends okay
oh really
um oh what in the hell is how do you get
a an eight is it an eight I'd be
questioning myself that all the time
how'd you get an eight where were you
how'd you get an eight it was through
friends but
um
you're punching oh
you're punching I was I was jumping and
punching I can't say that how hard was
it listen right it's all right then
don't say that what's easy at you what's
the lowest number you've been out with
you've been out of the nights the
highest
two free right I've been up with and
what was the difference between them
their mannerisms what was the difference
between the two because I know that one
was for the ball and had all the chat
but you tell me
yeah and then
but more of like I'd say is a gentle
they're both gentlemen's but then
I think outside with the eight more
because the three four was just
would I say crazy
that you would just be crazy people so
we can't say all fours are crazy just
the one that you meet most of the men
you meet are crazy come on a few a
couple
um
what was it about you that got what did
you look like how did you dress where
were you how did you behave it what made
you get a seven or an eight and how did
he treat you it was just me being me and
honestly
you being used bad
[Laughter]
how long did that last
oh
can I just making this up can I just
guess it did the lower numbers last
longer than the higher numbers yeah okay
but then I feel like the lower number I
feel like I had forced myself to stay
there for a lot longer than I wanted to
so if you didn't force yourself which
one would last the longer so the lower
number
the higher number
is that was it or is it all falling out
there and yeah yeah
and then when you come down to earth
then what they just made me money and
clothes and go out I don't you know what
that's not actually something I look for
in a guy like I'm not saying you look
for it I'm saying you had it I mean if
it's not it's nice as far as a surprise
but it's not something like
that makes me jump in the sky like so
where's where did that where's what's
the best place that the eight took you
compared to the four um
it was like a full day sort of like an
event like out to eat about that Ryan
and dining yeah new aerial Hotel
because at the time I was still living
at my mom's okay
it's the young lady how'd you get an
eight
how the hell did you get an eight that's
what I wanna how'd you get a night
I've got five and you got an eight how'd
you get eight life ain't Fair how did
you get an eight what did you do where'd
you meet him how did you get an eight
um
that's such a hard question I don't know
I'm I'm oh they're not actually an easy
one how'd you catch a black man
um as a white woman how'd you get a
black man so I mean I'm pretty confident
I'm pretty outgoing so you know if I'm
out and I see someone I find attractive
um I'm not shy so go to go talk to that
person I think
um living in the UK and having moved to
the UK
um I think British women and North
American women are very different in
that in that respect
she approaches men but yeah well it's
true and I think sometimes men are quite
shocked if you kind of come up to them
so I don't know there is another man in
the room I don't know
um
if confidence is something that that
might make you kind of like okay you
know she's approached me
um
but but yeah I don't know I'm I
I'm pretty driven I'm educated I'm
pretty well spoken
um quite fun to be around
um I think so
um yeah and I and you're looking for you
yeah you want to get married you want to
settle down so I I actually was married
so I think I'm I'm kind of in the
category that maybe he said before
because I I married quite young
um so I I met him when I was 23 we were
married by the time I was 25.
um I was like you and said I would never
get married I I never kind of had a
thought
um of actually getting married
um and yeah you know I I was too young
and in retrospect you know there are
some definitely some moves I've made in
my life that I shouldn't have made
um so yeah so and I stayed in that
relationship way longer than I should
have um I was unhappy for for years a
lot of women say that that somebody
forced them to stay I get sick and tired
of women say oh I would have left sooner
why didn't well if you're in a
relationship and it don't work so you're
not gonna work why are you dragging it
out why don't women just get up and
leave I wish I had I wish I had the
courage to
um I very much I I don't know what it is
within me that I I really don't like
confrontation like if someone is upset
with me whether it's something I did or
not
um it makes me very very uncomfortable
so I did stay in a relationship you know
I stayed in that relationship way longer
um then then I should have I should have
had the courage and I wish I had the
courage because you know it kind of that
that took all my 20s
um so when he finally left a year after
I said I wanted a divorce
um when he did finally leave I was you
know I was 31 and it was like for the
for the first time of most of my adult
life I was single so I obviously spent
that time like trying to get to know
myself trying to get to know you know
the man that I do want
um and and really work on myself you
know I've you know been you know
building businesses and you know really
trying to better myself do personal
development but now I'm 34 and it's kind
of like I am at a stage where no I
actually do want to meet someone but I
think I'm in this category where it's
like you know I am 34 now I have been
married before so it's um I am finding
it difficult I am finding it difficult
um old
old women who get to a certain age and
now almost like they're The Leftovers so
it's like it's terrifying yeah so you
know I do find myself you know maybe I
am in that category
um
have you got any children I do not have
children oh wow yeah you're right you're
still fine I'm telling her that that's
not true that's not true you're still
not fine don't tell her that don't tell
her that it don't lie to her I've
listened to the women that will lie to
you I won't lie to you
time is passing and running and passing
and passing and running and passing and
you gotta catch up which might be too
late but hey how I think a lot of them
people that
then their relationships weren't
successful I hear a lot of the times
like it was toxic or he was toxic yeah
but then imagine them guys that that
cause referring to
um they call them insults they might be
deep locked away in your friend zone but
I reckon they're not going to be toxic
so I reckon if you gave them a chance
but then I guess they wouldn't get
looking because you didn't like them
physically facially or the image or
confidence you know I'm saying so I
wanted to ask you a lot slack so if
there was someone don't forget your show
it is right yeah yeah yours yours yours
come on all right so basically now
who would
so I had a client
and um he
didn't have much money but it was really
nice like he's a good guy a nice guy
he was going bold
to like receding hairline it was kind of
fat
and also he was about like five free or
something so what is a guy like that
supposed to do honestly like in your
opinion
because I don't think none of you look
would
Entertainer elevate make money become
successful right work on himself
personal development there was something
I went to like saying a lady when you
said you're working so since you got
divorced have you had any partners
um
dated
yeah a lot of people say dating and
nowadays digital means dating with sex
so I'm gonna say not caught in I'm gonna
say dating have you dated I have dated
yes right have you seen any nice black
Englishman me attracted to well not yet
Englishmen men in the UK
yeah yeah well my my partner was here
I've lived here for 11 years all right
yeah so I was yeah in this country when
I was married yeah well I got the same
accent then I know it doesn't want to go
I love it
she takes some and what she won't drop
her accent see what I mean that's a part
of it Auntie it's a Oh that's oh that's
the attraction they like American women
yeah you just gotta send a voice note oh
your voice are you from Canada yeah so
approach man
leave a voice note
be Charming be funny be bubbly and have
a love yeah right
you want to get married
Are you seriously looking when you go on
a date is it just for a date or do you
go on a date saying you know what I want
to go on a date with the intention of
getting a husband because me personally
when you get to sort of Asia you're out
you just gotta go for it and don't just
cut the crap like this is what I'm after
time zone now marry me you don't want to
settle down that's it yeah no I I am
seriously looking and when I do have you
know conversations with men if it you
know
it
if it's not going to lead there and I'm
direct saying I I want a relationship
I'm not
um you know because I am I'm on dating
apps because I am you know that's like
the number one place to to find men
especially you know I I work in a school
so I'm not finding any men there it's an
all girls school
um and my businesses are online so you
know then the natural thing to do is is
to meet men online so so yeah so when I
do have conversations like I am on here
with the intention of a relationship if
you want anything less don't waste my
time because you know there's
so this I want you to recap you got
divorced and you're working on yourself
name the things that you've done to work
on yourself to make you get into walls
being a wife
and to the role of being a wife well you
know when women said they're working on
myself I always put myself what did I
mean working on myself or what so
um so just in terms of my mindset as
well you know having to figure out well
you know why couldn't I leave
um so I'm just reading a lot of
um personal development books um some of
that is to do with business but I think
it definitely relates
um to you you growing as a person you
understanding you know why you like what
you like why you don't like what you
don't like
um you know what what vibrations are you
giving out to the world I think when I
was with him
um
vibration crap I've got to laugh at that
I was trying to hold it straight focus
and we're using vibrations
could it be that you have you ever
considered the thought that maybe you
didn't leave because
you valued having a man in your life
because we need men because they can do
things we can't do
why I didn't because of that would you
consider that because you're talking
about all these personal development
things but
that's surrounded by you and why you
didn't leave for yourself but have you
considered the fact that you might not
have left because maybe he provided
things for you that you can't provide
for yourself
um and you didn't want to necessarily
leave that yeah he definitely may have
done just in terms of companionship but
in that relationship what about DIY who
did the majority of that around the
house not him
um I also earned more than him
significantly more so I was the one who
was kind of
um The Breadwinner if you if you want to
say it like that
um so I think that was something also
over time where could he change a tire
had him could he change a tire no didn't
drive so yeah so so I'm really glad you
left yeah me too did you wait him hey
you said
um he wasn't there he wasn't late he was
good looking he was good looking
um and you know he is a very nice guy
which is probably why I I did stay
because we got on you know we could we
could go for dinner you know we
obviously we were together for eight
years you know we knew each other
um
but yeah I think that's why now I'm also
very much I know what I want now because
I was in a relationship where
um you know he couldn't provide for me
um we didn't have children he wanted
children
um but I was not going to have children
with someone who you know maternity
leave in this country you get basically
half your salary if I'm the breadwinner
and you can't provide for me when you
know I'm at home with our child or
having our child then you know sorry why
was he not working uh he worked
part-time the entire time we're together
and you know apparently looking for jobs
of course when he finally did move out
he got one you know a couple weeks later
so he obviously wasn't looking that hard
do you think that you would that you
would that you were the head of the
household
yeah if it sounds like you led the
relationship that you wore the pants
um
yeah but at the same time he expected
wifey as well so that to me always
didn't sit right because it's like how
can how can I be the one who's basically
paying most of the bills but also then
come home and cook for you when I'm the
one who's at work all day and you worked
part-time you got very comfortable oh he
did give it he forced you into your
masculine energy nobody that's rubbish
but she was in her masculine energy
before that's
rubbished into nothing you know what I'm
saying he wasn't pulling his way she
just stood there and said she just sat
there and said earlier she does not want
a man that earns more than her I don't
know what's wrong with having a man no
you did no no you don't want you don't
you don't want a man that owns less than
you hmm
I don't see that
for what you let me put it this way
right
you really said you'd be you you've been
divorced you're in your like you're in
your mid-30s you're overweight you want
to talk black command and you want a man
you're you're an entrepreneur you've got
businesses plus you work and you want a
man that earns more than you you want a
[__] miracle
doesn't necessarily have to earn more
with me but it has to be it has to be
something that's equal I I don't want to
be in a relationship again where that
um you know that there isn't that there
isn't that like at least Financial
equality right so all right then
you said
equality so yes and either the same as
you or less than you if you're a
part-time husband had cleaned the house
done other things around the house
cooked you dinner and you just went out
and worked and he worked part-time would
that have made a difference
no was it the money that made a
difference
um it was it was a cumulative of things
uh then if you had a man that was
perfect except that he earned less than
you what difference would that make
um
because women always say men don't care
about your money yeah I've never been
there I have never ever been out with a
man that's more than me and I've never
ever been out of a man that I've had to
go out and pay
oh he's always been a man I've never had
a man be less than a man because of what
he earned that sounds like you were kind
of in that area of paying for things or
yeah it became as I suppose it certainly
became habit yeah and did you lose
respect for him yeah yeah there we go
because she was the bloke in the
relationship with an expose they had the
relationship she was leading why would
you want to be of a man that part-time
that works and that's the whole point
you get if sometime when you get two
fights together they grow together they
support each other and you said that you
were you innate and he Master he was
like a five and
if you don't want to be improved he
couldn't be improved yeah so you can't
say oh he made her do this he made her
do that he made her do that because he
didn't Make Her Say I Do no exactly he
didn't and I'm not saying he did at all
yeah I understand what you're saying but
I'm just because I know she's trying to
put it all say oh but he done this and
he done that and I'm saying that no you
chose it it didn't work out [__] happens
yeah it wasn't his fault it wasn't your
fault it was just a bad combination yeah
which is what now I'm trying to like
learn from that situation you can't do
anything in life that you know every
with every you know failure comes
success but with every failure you have
to learn the lesson from it which so
what did you do wrong in a relationship
um
probably lots of things you could
probably list lots of things now you
what do you think not what he would say
you said you've been working on yourself
with mindset what did you do wrong what
was it that you could have done better
that you've learned now that you could
carry because you might make the same
mistakes into a net relationship you
said you've been working on yourself
what have you learned that you need to
change to take into the next
relationship so um in that situation
um I was very very negative that also
had to do with my job as well so I think
I saw everything in a negative light
um where now some of the things I am
working on is is things like
affirmations things like you know not
dwelling in that negativity and so
that's certainly one thing but also
being able to communicate um I wasn't a
good communicator
um I still find it very difficult
um to tell people my feelings especially
people I'm closest to
um so that's that is something that I
definitely need to change you know being
able to openly communicate what I'm
frustrated with or what's not working
for me
um and when I did eventually vocalize
those feelings it would come out as like
an eruption because it'd been building
up for such a long period of time
um so yeah so I think that's that's
definitely something that I need to
continue to improve on
so how are you working on yourself to
catch the man that you want
being more orderly in my household
making sure I always make the bed every
morning making sure that I'm polishing
down the surfaces and always doing the
washing up making sure the house smells
nice it smells nice airing it out every
day
um I'm trying to get better at cooking I
do cook and but I'd like to learn more
dishes I know enough dishes that I have
something to make every day of the week
but I'd like to experiment a bit more
and try some new things what's your
favorite thing to cook at the moment
either a lasagna or Ramen okay the zone
is good lasagna with some salad oh I
like to salad and some sour cream on top
with some croutons maybe I hate croutons
no
it's like leftover old bread you know
you've got all bread make croutons
leftover toast make croutons
right young lady
what are you doing to improve yourself
to get the man that you want everything
getting 19 to cancel you that's a big
step for you it's going to change your
life
trust me
see I can cook
I think the only thing I need to do is
probably like I have like those one-off
days where I like get a bit lazy listen
right It's gotta be sight wrong
otherwise you would have had no that's
what I have them one-off days where I
get a bit lazy and don't want to do no
cleaning don't want to do no washing
well I have a dishwasher but you're
lucky you're so lucky I love that I
thank God for that thing
it's so good my sink would probably be
full every single day
um
I'd come in your house I'd lock
everything away in a box and just leave
you one cup one plate one life one for
one what happens I might actually have
to do that but other than that's say
like that because that's all you need to
do to change to improve to catch a man
I've you know what I've spent so much
time alone and I've spent so much time
getting to know who I am as well as who
I am as a mum and who I am without being
a mom like to my child and sort of like
I've spent the last three since 2020
I've spent since the pandemic just taken
that time so what have you learned about
yourself what are you going to take onto
your next relationship what is there
that you think that is the constant in
your relationships that I want a man and
this is where I keep on messing up and
this is what I believe I have to change
not what they believe but you believe
you have to change I think I need to
stop expecting
someone to do like people like people to
think
I don't know how to explain it I should
I need to stop expecting people to do
things or like take on like mentally if
I think oh maybe they're on the same
page as me and I stopped expecting that
and just sort of like I'm just because I
get so disappointed in people and their
actions and then I sit there and I'm
like I can't even be disappointed in
them because I shouldn't have like
put any sort of ounce of thought of
maybe they would
you know on the same page as me do you
put in your belief in the wrong people
yeah yeah
right messy bedroom lady what else do
you need to improve to trap this man he
knows he's watching you now sell
yourself to him even though you've got
him oh god
um
yeah I guess just uh be a little bit
more domesticated uh because at the
moment I can only cook seafood pasta
so I know he wants something that's like
a 10 minute dish Seafood takes about
five minutes to cook pasta by the time
the kettle's book that's lazy that I'm a
food that's lazy she comes at it as a
foodie and I'm saying to you about your
man and you're saying seafood pasta are
you trying to fall I love the seafood
pasta is that what you women do you go
out there and you make it sound all
fancy like yeah I'm gonna cook you
Seafood faster and then you sit down on
the internet you get your phones out and
then it's like yeah I've done seafood
pasta I don't seafood pasta take to make
um like I don't know 21. because how
long does the pasta take to make right
yeah so by the time the past is balls
it's like it's all over in it I can make
that one and then I can make the Gigi
Hadid pasta okay what's that it's the
pasta with the vodka but Halal we don't
have vodka so we just put uh nothing
it's basically just pasta I think with
like uh tomatoes onions parmesan cheese
yeah it's very basic because anyone had
it
it sounds a bit too basic for us it's
the Gigi had deep pasta guys
some weird rubbish and then call it give
it all fancy name you just said pasta
with some cheese on it and then maybe
vodka if you if you know if you're not
Muslim and then and then it's like yeah
Gigi yummy yeah I don't know I basically
need to become a bit more domesticated I
need to start
um you know learning some more dishes
Moroccan Asian Persian Iraqi whatever
where did you come from I'm originally
Moroccan
[Music]
don't tell me that your mum's giving up
because you made your mom give up
because you didn't want to learn you're
both worthless right because I'm gonna
get someone to teach you look I had to
cut my rocket you know but what's so
hard about it it's just it is hard it's
all about prep you're lazy not only
okay so you're saying you can cook one
dish yeah then yeah what do you guys
have for the rest of the week
um
eat out a lot actually we we go to a lot
of restaurants
um
how long have you been with him you're
in a half
don't don't Auntie Jenny this is a
message oh no right you've wasted a year
and a half of this woman
right I know she can cook a Gigi pasta
and some other seafood pasta come on
you're taking her at the restaurant so
when you see the potential in me come on
there's nobody what you need to do young
man right is to get her in the kitchen
get her a cookbook the same way she's on
the phone get the YouTube out on the TV
so that she can learn to cook buy talk
don't take her out to no more anybody
see it at the restaurant of a man say
that's the one that can't cook make her
go home and cook right make her go home
and learn to cook the same way because
it'd be cheaper for you to send her to a
class
right because I [__] the same
political in classes she can go classes
it's cheaper to send it to a class right
than to waste your money
do not waste your money do you want to
be when she's married you're taking out
to dinner you can't get home cooked meal
I mean look at the woman she had to go
out there and work come home and cook
the food
you know what I mean you want a woman
that's going to come home and cook not
no Gigi pasta and seafood pasta like
she's been slaving over a hot stove
she's faking it might get her in the
kitchen a Moroccan woman that can't cook
Moroccan food
so does he pay for the restaurant every
time you go out because he doesn't want
you to be with him of course he does so
every week every day like most parts of
the week you like a restaurant listen
right as far as you can hear the man's a
real man respect for the man they said
you're full right respect for the man
right so he's holding the man's duties
that's why she's with him because
everything she loves about it because
he's a real man she needs to step up he
needs to do better
because she's punching
she's gonna love you she's punching she
is punching I don't know where you're
with her because she's punching you can
do better
can't cook
it's the this is how the in sales get
you know what I mean because they go for
the good men and then afterwards and men
are like why can't we get a woman I can
cook for her I don't mind eating a
seafood pasta every day
on my wage listen I love Seafood does
anyone love Seafood here I love Seafood
but don't go on like seafood
like it's all that great stuff Seafood
takes what about a lobster boil have you
good lobster boil or seafood I want to
do that soon I'm gonna do that I love
meat
I would love to do that you love me I
love meat more than Seafood really what
meat do you cook I love so it's my I
have to say lamb I love lamb as well I
use that use that use the Moroccan
we do we do intestines
right and this is this is what makes me
crazy about women yeah Morocco and I
love it but I can't cook [__] I can cook
can you cook American food I can't cook
all of the Moroccan dishes but I can
cook some and can you cook the reasons
that you like the ones that I like yes
okay but there's sounds that are quite
hard because I'd have to go to like an
out of London butcher to get like the
certain meats that I need can you cook a
tagine I don't like the cookies because
that's the problem yeah
I have to get pasta and put it inside
before pasta because and they're
Moroccan rice I'm sorry but what is that
nonsense you put sugar on top of it
because that's not no rice
um but
but that's Jamaican and Chinese mix so I
quite like diverse in what I cook that's
good though yeah it's good diversity all
right blessings I can't see the um
yeah
oh thank you I do a lot of people to
think that I've forgotten
how many kids do you got one that's what
I'm gonna know we're gonna start from
you how many kids do you want with your
husband well we've spoken about this I
only want to
boy well his family had two my family
had two I just want to stick to two how
old are you now I'm 28.
okay how many of you'd like to have
realistically thinking about the age
getting the man realistically no two as
well
okay
we're kind of happy with the one okay he
talks my ear off right
I don't know how to do that oh
um I would be happy if I got my little
girl I'd be happy if you had she was
tired but um yeah I'm kind of happy with
just having a one my little boy oh I
meant that I didn't mean it yeah yeah I
meant it I didn't mean it
I don't want it to have no more children
let's have a husband when a child's
growing up and enjoyed the hospital she
don't need to be having no more children
don't fall asleep I'm looking for a
single parent man for you
would you date Guys with Kids yeah 100
100 like there's I really feel like
there's no looking down at a guy that's
got especially like if he looks after
his kids I think that's even more
ticking box that is so stupid you women
will go out there and you will see a
five and don't want him but find a man
with children attractive that you'll
find a member of a dog attractive you
not do that you see a man out there and
he love his child with him especially if
he's on your feet oh that's really good
who don't find the memory children that
they're attracted if you see a man out
there and it's him and his child and
he's out there
what woman out there finds it
unattractive but that goes with any men
they could be four five it's just nice
but what I'm trying to say is that you
will see a five with a child is more
attractive than a five without a child
he's not messed up
do you understand what I'm saying am I
making any sense to anyone I get what
you mean I think what you mean but are
you so crazy
no women women are crazy
I think it's in our what is it like in
our nature to go for the guy who's like
has children because then we're like oh
look he's had children when I say like
children because there's guys out there
that have children that don't look after
their kids yeah so you mean like he's
present he's involved and even if like
okay I mean if you go to the park and
you you're there with your son out of
his son you're like oh yeah it warms my
heart it makes me feel like full for
that person because and that child
especially because it's not many
children out here I mean I talk to my
dad but I'm not like I didn't grow up
with him so it's just nice to see that
that's active in the child's life yeah I
think that's what it is I don't actually
look at him like I think it's just more
of that's actually so sweet generally
sweet this is I don't I don't know
I don't think seeing it's a dad who's
good with his kids
should be viewed as something that's
like oh that's that's really good
because that should just be the standard
obviously you've come from a different
experience I can't relate to that I've
had a really great dad he's been there
the whole time so when I see someone
else being a great dad of course I get
that warm feeling I'm a woman of course
I'm gonna be like oh that's that's
lovely but I don't see it as something
that makes them
necessarily more attractive in the sense
that being a good dad is a virtue
because I think being a good dad should
just be the standard if you have a child
no but in also in saying that it's like
for me as well the guy's also got to
accept a woman with kids because you've
also got if a woman's going to accept a
man with kids
the woman comes with kids you've got to
accept them as a whole obviously if it's
not more than a relationship you're not
really gonna be involving kids but if
it's going to be going to relationship
status and further run
you do want to know that he's actually
going to be okay with your own kid so I
feel like that's something that
especially like where I've been in a
situation I've been in a situation where
my mum got remarried in Morocco and the
guy was you didn't have no kids but he
was nasty towards me if I had my mom's
back he was nasty towards me in my mom's
face he was all oh
and he was horrible
and it was only it took like four years
for her to actually like notice but
Live to Tell to tell
so women
if you saw a man
and he's a five
what advice would you give him
to reach your level
starting
no this young lady here
just because this one just because
you've got a money don't mean you're
going to be included because if I have
my way I'm gonna find him a better woman
but yeah
how would you improve a five
how would I improve a five rather than
bringing him down but how would you
improve a five
um
I would just tell him to
like
get busy like go and do something that
you really enjoy and then it makes you
money
um because money equals
Freedom you know it's going to give you
Freedom it's going to give you power
um so the only way I was gonna get in
your view is to make some money he needs
to make some money yeah I'm sorry that's
something everyone's a five and he made
money what would that make him
um
it would make that make him a six or
would it make him a five with money
without making more attractive to women
yes it would more women would um give
him a chance basically so money were
making money yeah if he's if he's out in
these places women know he's got money
and you know he's ambitious and you know
he's
I don't know it's like I feel like he
it's not just money like there's a
certain energy that he needs to carry
because there's men who have money but
they still don't have women you know
it's not like every man who's who's Rich
has women throwing themselves at him it
doesn't work like that like you have to
have some kind of energy towards you
like uh to you sorry
to be able to attract the woman so
are you dominant are you alpha male are
you fully in your masculine energy or
are you fake energy he could be a five
and still be masculine just that he
don't look the part that someone asking
you how does he improve himself make and
it's got to be something by these things
that you can hold on to I don't want to
hear about oh I need to change yeah he
feels yeah it might be successful making
money elevating
um and then working on your parents for
example if you're overweight go to the
gym get on a diet work on yourself
um if you said he's losing hair go get a
hair transplant you know there's so many
different ways
don't know why everyone's got so silent
because the things that you just said if
I had to say that to a woman she'd get
upset and then they'll get cause of fat
shaming and things like that the things
that just came out of your mouth if I
had to say them to a man to a woman
all the women will get upset the things
that you just said
well then well they shouldn't get upset
because it's it's the truth I'm just I'm
just being realistic here like if you if
you are okay you should try to
understand yourself and I'm sure a lot
of overweight women are working on you
just said get money you just said get
money yeah you just said I said get
ambitious and get ambitious you said
um if you've got here if you're going
bored right go and get hair transplant
right say if I tell the woman your hair
looks like [__] go and get away go and
get go and get extensions your fat go to
the gym you know you're only a five go
and put on some better clothes that's
what basically you tend to tell the man
to do and do
well yeah improve yourself because I'm
being real like just improve yourself
otherwise no woman's gonna look in your
direction I'm really sorry
superficial is what women want women are
superficial
of course
you can scroll down at the bottom
I'm coming
do you know what I'm touching it my
one's touched Mama's touch screen I'm
sorry I'm more up to date than
newsletter
oh it's no fashion with buttons like
this okay
I think that's why a lot of guys go
Thailand and all that play all them
places right okay why is that because
the insoles so they go Thailand and get
wet that way yeah women are more
and they're more traditional as well
that's why a lot of men are doing that
these are all the super chats I get you
now right I'm gonna read the superset so
let me speak
um Maggie The Substitute Teacher
sending support see you all very soon
yeah hope to see you
and welcome new member
Chico Rock one
welcome
and Walter basically
love what you're doing he says thank you
very much
how do you go on this old
I think you use the mouse oh he's the
mouse oh my gosh
[Laughter]
I'm so sorry I can't believe that one
was better than this
oh gosh
why don't you just use the keeper this
one that's easier isn't it just go down
like that on the mouse and then
it's moving
is it moving
why does it stop moving
I've got I moved it I don't know how
right
oh I can do that now
right um black built like a conquering
King ruthless truth she is an adjustable
fire but has the ability to get to six
when she dolls up
um D middle woman wants a unicorn she
was the man in the relationship she has
hit the wall
Julio Colon Julio Colon 37 virgin
husband material insulin Chicago hi I
tweeted you Pearl if you come to Chicago
now that's the first Super Chat from
Julio Colon
big Elvis
the chief Rosenberg thank you D blue
shirt and his wife School but I don't
know she can be safe
yeah I'm reviewing that
she got my news and take her out for
food
and after I helped him accent 436 to be
fair make an attempt goes a long way I
don't think guys expect you to be a
Gourmet Chef taking the advice you're
here today and actually applying it
means you are improving
Doug MPA hi Doug big girl on the couch
say she's a seven to a black man and a
five to everyone else what makes her
think that black men should accept less
than other men
Charlie Brown Auntie what main two
personality traits or habits do you
think a woman needs in order
to prepare for becoming a wife
fat cuddly Panda I am 20. I know I'm
young
but with how the media is showing only
how bad women and dating sites
I am 20. I'm I know I'm young but with
how the media is showing only the bad
women and dating sites women only go on
there for popularity how do you suggest
I can find a woman I can date
go out get out there and look at the
women
don't go and date insights look at the
right where was I how do you improve a
five in your eyes to bring him up to
your scratch
um
I actually I I agree
um because
I have I I know someone personally who
you know I would say most women wouldn't
find conventionally attractive
um
he's he's quite he's quite shorts he's
like five I think he's like five five
five six
um but he does have a lot of money he's
very successful
um he
um and he regularly plays tennis so he's
like you know very active
um and with that and it's not
necessarily about the money right but
with money and with success comes
confidence and I think some people don't
tie the two together enough
um if
the the only way to get successful and
the only way to make that kind of money
you have to work you have to work hard
you have to develop yourself otherwise
it's just not going to happen you know
money doesn't you know grow on trees it
comes from a lot of hard work and effort
it comes from you know discipline it
comes from Habits it comes from you know
all of those things cumulative and I
think putting all of those things
together if someone who you know would
consider themselves a five or someone
who is a five
um but maybe they have a below average
income or you know that that comes with
that like might have you know poor
self-esteem they might not be confident
so if they were to get those things
um I think those personality traits come
along naturally as well
um so that's what I would say so it's
not necessarily about having the money
it's about what it takes to get the
money and how that changes a person
so it goes down to money
but it's not though it's not because I
don't know I'm I'm around a lot of
successful people who you know a few
years ago they were a very different
person because it takes grind it takes
hustle it takes working on something
every single day but what if you get a
man that's just a five and he's a nine
to fiver he just goes punches and comes
at nine to five regular
everyday person
what's wrong with a regular video person
I didn't say he was a bus driver
regular wage
he goes to work and come down
what's wrong with him
there's nothing wrong with him but he
could be doing extra
like what well if I use myself as an
example I know okay men maybe don't rate
money but I work in nine to five I'm a
teacher but when I when I come home at
night I have my online businesses I
trade
um if if I can do it so can a man you
know if just because you have the one
job doesn't stop you from doing the
others and again it's the others that I
think help you grow
so a man can't go unless he's got others
like other side hustles to buff up his
that's what I'm hearing because the way
I'm saying is that
you're a lady that was solder wants to
get married I'm not talking about your
parents can't talk about you now you're
gonna go and you're gonna work your
husband's gonna go he's gonna work and
you're both gonna come in and start
doing your side hustles
no I think once you are in a
relationship and you grow together it
becomes different and I think this is
where
um
so you were shut down if you became if
you was in a relationship now with a
serious relationship would you consider
shutting down your cytosis for marriage
yeah and for children I think I would
more so for children because
um if I do have a man at least
what's that one is the other one so you
want to shut it down for your husband
but you're showing them for the kids
that he's gonna help you produce
but there's more time like with kids
comes like you have to give time so you
have to give time to your husband no
it's true yeah you're right and it's I'm
not saying this is what women out there
treat your husbands as practice for when
you have your children
um
yeah
me yeah because you saw yourself like
when I said that you sort of like she
slapped me
oh no no no you didn't hit no no I just
think I feel like guys need
fives need just confidence little boost
in their confidence go if it will happen
if you get a five of a five of
confidence
a regular five come on you must go on
the bus and see bus drivers right just
don't sing they're confident they just
don't sing the same the same song that
the Pied Piper singing along
such as explain that to me the same song
that every guy would be singing out
there but those are the ones that those
are the women those are the men that the
women are falling for the same old
patter no those are the ones that will
say falling for I mean
no
but then
yeah yeah yeah you think about it yeah
because then you look at the bus drivers
the reason I'm saying that the reason
I'm saying that because you know I I
went out but I've reached nine to five
still nine to five I've always had more
than him
he's got his own place
he just likes going to work and coming
and watching his movies and chilling
you know I've got the properties and
he's got the money
because he just goes to work and he
doesn't really spend a lot of money
and said look at him he just looks like
any other he's listening with navy joke
but I think that well what is it about
him that made you pick him
I didn't pick me pick me
huh
I don't believe that women should be
picking me
well something may have attracted you to
to him does he pick me
when when a woman to go and pick them up
I don't find attractive
I find that men don't like when
They Don't Really respect when women
approach them
I'll find that women should wait in
there but what attracts you to him
is perfect oh that's cute I like that
okay
he's that perfect that you don't do
social media wow I hear that okay Auntie
we're going to move to the Auntie Jenny
Channel guys so uh guys on the